citizens of the reject Nation I am just walking
out of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. this is my
non-spoiler review and I am in love I am back
to feeling that Marvel magic this is not only
everything I want from a Marvel movie this is
everything I want from a movie this is everything
I want from art that's made me feel this was a
magic trick where James Gunn basically put me
in a state of all and then punctuated that awe
with Despair and joy so I was left with this
insane Whirlwind of just feeling it's all the
characters you love and being reminded of why
you love them it is everything you want from
the action spectacle in that the action has
weight to it this felt so tangible especially
considering it is so bright and Cosmic and
allowed there are elements of this that are
so comic Booky this might be the most comic
bookie of my favorite comic book films in that a
lot of times like you add a comic book Element and
it doesn't quite work for the medium of comics
this is insane there are lovecraftian villains
there are chimera-esque villains there are um
fleshy organic planetoids there's so much stuff
that is pure Jim Sterling Cosmic that somehow
Works in this medium and I and I cannot believe
it exists this well this balance and again that's
all because you trust in these characters and your
investment and your love for these characters
really makes you able to be a part of any one of
these moments and be like yeah that feels like
it affects me yeah this is something that I'm
feeling and a lot of that is obviously tied to the
chemistry of the Guardians but it's also tied into
the editing the the writing the directing and here
also ties to the villain the villain here the high
evolutionary is a top tier comic villain he's able
to be both enormous like not quite mustache twirly
but big and bold and loud and zod-ish but also
manipulative in a really contained way there's
a lot of elements of tiny nuanced decisions that
make you hate him because of a contained malignant
move or or decision that it's really interesting
when juxtaposed with a lot of the big swings and
we've been on this journey with the Guardians
for a long time and at the first film I consider
you know about a family and then the second film
obviously about family and then the third film is
about found family the first film I'd say mother
second father third about self and you just feel
this connection between all three films that is so
unique to any Trilogy this is easily my favorite
of the Marvel films as far as trilogies go this
is probably tied with the first film I need to
decide if the first or this film is my favorite
it is definitely my favorite trilogy because as
I said this this is amongst my favorite comic
films of all time this is either my top five or
top three MCU movies this thing is crazy I digress
I'm gonna I'm gonna break down some elements for
you so we've got the Duos right we've got the
gabora Star-Lord relationship which I think is
fascinating and I think they do a really good
job and actually exceeded my expectations that
was one of the only elements I was worried about
was how they'd handle that relationship and they
definitely maneuver between two extremes and all
the while you're really really in love with hope
and I think that's exactly what this movie needed
then you've got the Mantis Drax relationship which
I think really really is an interesting byproduct
of having the holiday special came out when it did
what that relationship is is not just between them
it's not just this beautiful platonic relationship
that I think was really well written so it doesn't
become anything more it also impacts the overall
team in a really interesting way in this film
the team Dynamic that comes from how drags and
mantis relate is really wonderful especially in
relating to Gamora you've got rocket who will
test the very limits of what you think you can
feel for an animated creature special effects are
at a new level here especially with emotional
connection man that that uncanny valley is broken
and how much you can feel and and the depths
of which you can believe in something that's
ones and zeros Bradley Cooper Take a Bow good God
and there's a really cool use of timeline there
there's a really cool use of chronology and I love
how jarring it is and I think that's the only way
this movie works is by testing you by vexing You
by putting you through the ringer emotionally
because all these characters are full of trauma
including as ever one of the MVPs of the entire
MCU nebula she is trauma incarnate her Arc has
been beautiful to see Karen Gillen is such a force
in nature as an actor like you can put her in that
position and have her have that character and you
can just love this black-eyed evil daughter of
Thanos that isn't evil that's overcome everything
that you think hates but Love's just so impossibly
deeply and that's so special and then you've got
Cosmo this dog we want wanted to see in movies
forever is here and she is wonder she has magic
and then some new characters I don't want to spoil
anything of but uh Rockets lady is everything you
want to do from the comics and all the characters
in that uh almost Toy Story two I think it's toy
no Toy Story one Toy Story one asks are exactly
what you want out of that scene where you discover
the origins of rocket that he's kept so close
to the vest for all these years it's these
characters so that juxtaposed with your hatred
for high evolutionary that mixed with the cosmic
Wonder of what this builds out to it is absolutely
stunning what they're able to accomplish and then
you've got the scale of it right so the scope of
the Marvel universe is always a struggle basically
with Marvel you're always having to have uh ever
escalating like world ending events but it doesn't
always work because basically if everything is
an Avengers level event nothing is an Avengers
level event right so this is the first movie that
to me feels like Infinity War feels like end game
feels like Stakes feels like there's weight but
also that there's weight outside of your team
like obviously we don't live in the MCU but it
definitely feels like there is something at stake
that could affect you not in as directive away
as you know I'm in harm but you want the world
to feel plausible and that something could happen
that could harm you in some way and the way they
build the stakes here make it feel like that could
somehow impact you and that's really special with
a Guardians of the Galaxy film uh let's talk about
a couple of the negatives the negative I had with
Adam Warlock definitely went away in the beginning
I didn't love the characterization about a warlock
um actually feel like he was it's funny actually
it's it's kind of talking to the comics in the
beginning he feels like when a writer doesn't
know how to write Adam Warlock but they do it
on purpose so the Adam Warlock characterization
is I think intentionally misleading and then they
know him so well it writes itself it does solve
some of those elements so by the time it lands
I do really like Adam Warlock I do really think
that what they have him end up like is worth that
initial maybe not so great of a decision in the
way he's introduced there's a an expediency to it
that bothers me still but it's all juice worth
the squeeze in its situational uh awareness So
Adam Warlock is a slight negative another negative
I've heard is there's a bit of whiplash in how the
drama and comedy goes back and forth I completely
patently disagree with that I think that's what
makes this movie special is that Whiplash I
completely disagree with people think it's too
dark and too full of Despair that is what makes
this movie sing so people that are saying that
um we had a different experience we'd
perform so those aren't negatives for
me uh I guess still negative I really
have is man this is a damn near five-star
film um I think the biggest negative I
experienced was I would have loved I think
a little more you know I actually don't have any
log I was gonna try to like make something
negative that wasn't just now I'm trying to
find a problem with this movie I loved it it is so
special it is so what I needed it to be Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 one of my favorite MCU films
of all time one of my favorite comic films of all
time one is actually shared films of all time
James Gunn is about to make the DC Universe
something truly Monumental because this Trilogy
is the best Trilogy in the MCU and one of the best
trilogies in film and it sucked the landing and
I'm so happy thank you reject Nation please hit
the like hit that subscribe Bell please do comment
let me know what you guys thought of the movie I
tried to be as spoiler free as possible I am very
curious about the discourse of this film because I
walked out of the theater going like everyone's
gonna love it who can hate it apparently people
I know and trust so it is uh it's gonna be an
interesting discourse I adored it four and a half
maybe even five stars for me got a lot of love
for the Guardians a lot of love for James Gunn
a lot of love for Comic fans getting that love
back love the movie talk to you guys soon [Music]